[Music]
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
this is our Bible question and answer
program here at Su TV one of our
favorite programs because it allows us
to Clue Into Your thinking to answer
your questions and to do something that
we like to do and that's study the word
of God I am CA Murray and I'm in the
company of Pastor Steven bore and Pastor
David Salazar and we welcome you to this
particular program we've got some
interesting questions we always have
interest interesting questions and we
like to answer them as God gives us the
ability and the strength to do precisely
that should you want to get in on the
fund should you want to be part of this
program please send us your questions we
ask that you do send them to
TVM
tv.org
tv.
tv.org and we will get to them just as
soon as we can the questions are piling
up and we like that that's a good
problem to have but we will get to them
if you don't hear your question right
away we promise you we will get to it so
little patience of the Saints and we'll
get to them just as quickly as we
possibly can we make you this promise
that we'll always give you the answers
from from the word of God and we will
give them to you as best as we can uh
under the guidance of the Holy Spirit
I'm going to ask Pastor Salazar if you
would open our sitting today with prayer
and then we'll launch out into our
questions absolutely let us pray
heavenly father as we come before you we
thank you once again for allowing us to
open your word and to open to the truth
that is found in your inspiration I pray
that you will give us the power of the
Holy Spirit the discernment of the Holy
Spirit as well to guide the answers to
your word and that people may hear not
our own thinking our own opinion but
your word speaking through us we pray
this in Jesus name amen amen amen our
first question comes to us from
Gail in Toledo Washington I did not know
that there was a Toledo in
Washington but evidently there is a
Toledo in Washington and um she asked
the following question when I was
working as an RN I was required to work
every other weekend I recently learned
that I should have not kept the money
but donated it where does Ellen White
state that and since I wasn't aware of
that when I was working do I calculate
my income on those sabbaths for 25 years
and donate the money now that is her
question all right well I'll answer the
first part of the question she asked for
a specific
reference in the spirit of Prophecy
where maybe the servant of the Lord has
given guidance
into giving the money that is earned on
Sabbath for those that are work as
nurses Physicians and and that have to
do the perform the work on Sabbath to
put it in the storehouse of the Lord so
it actually there is a quote that is
found in medical Ministry page
216 paragraph two that actually
describes this and I'll read it it a say
Physicians need to cultivate a spirit of
self-denial and
self-sacrifice it may be necessary to
devote even the hours of the holy
Sabbath to relief of suffering of
humanity to the relief of suffering
Humanity but the fee for such labor
should be put into the treasury of the
Lord to be used for the word the poor
who need medical skill but cannot afford
to pay for it so here we have
the one quote or that she really
directly speaks to Physicians as far as
the fees that they will receive or the
money that they receive for working on
the holy day the Sabbath and this
includes of course nurses and those that
work in the medical field um that they
should be put for into the treasury of
the Lord and that should be ideally used
to help the poor that need a medical
attention and they cannot afford it so
that's what the Lord you know counseling
says the councel of say mhm
amen uh but then we have the second part
of the question right which is what
about all of the back pay for 25 years
uh what do we say about
that that's a good question that's few
folks it it you know I wanted to just
add one thing to the front part of the
question because I remember uh on I was
on the general conference committee when
they dealt with and brought out a paper
that dealt with Adventist working in
Advent hospitals on the Sabbath because
you cannot shut down a hospital on the
Sabbath uh God takes care of the poor
247 the sick 247 so um that same
suggestion was made uh just do surgeries
that are necessary not elective
surgeries if you put off till Sunday or
Monday do that but some care has to be
taken care of people have to be fed they
have to be taken care of so those things
have to be done but it was suggested not
demanded that following the council
Ellen White that those money be donated
uh to the church uh or to some aspect of
church work that would help uh those
less fortunate and in need of those
things as far as the 25 years of work is
concerned I think she should make an
honest attempt to try and repay some of
that money um it maybe a daunting cat
Tas she may not have the financial
wherewithal to do it but I think a good
faith honest attempt ought to be made to
try to do so uh maybe just put in a
little extra each week and keep that you
you may end up dying because it sounds
like she's retired before it's completed
but make an attempt to square up with
the Lord I think God would bless that
and uh I think that's the right thing to
do and as far as calculating 25 years of
work I think she would just have to do
an estimate because you know 25 years
ago um the salary was l because there
was less inflation so it' be very
difficult kind of difficult to calculate
the 25 years where she didn't know uh
sin is in he who knows that they're
supposed to do it and they don't do it
uh so you know I think I agree with uh
CA that she should make an effort you
know pay a little extra like we do with
our mortgage you know sometimes we pay a
little extra on our mortgage right uh do
that uh and uh the Lord is going to
understand that you're doing your best
to uh remedy the situation yes I think
the Lord will will bless her best
efforts it you put in another little
wrinkle there because there's inflation
uh things nowadays weren't like they
were before so how do you you without
being an accountant how do you
compensate for inflation uh raises cost
of living those kind of things all get
get in there so it can be kind of tough
but make an effort and I think God will
bless that effort pastor and you know I
just wanted to add that I've come across
I've come across several cases of people
who are nurses or Physicians and a lot
of them don't know that working on the
Sabbath uh should be given to the Lord
like that money unfortunately is not
taught is not being given any counsel
any anymore at least a lot of them have
come to me asking like oh I'm supposed
to do that and usually they find out
because of my wife she's a nurse and
when she has ever had to work which she
tries to avoid working on Sabbath OB
obviously but when she has to she always
has put that money to the Lord and when
she has shared that or something like
that that's when they start finding out
and I feel that sometimes we have maybe
neglected to teach that principle that
you know when we working on the Sabbath
is not really our money you know this is
this is the Lord's you know day and we
need to serve and use that time to you
know cultivate love for people love for
souls and that money that you get
because you're paid you have to be paid
as legally you have to do that should be
put into the storehouse of the Lord so
it's important
amen one more the wrinkle cuz my sister
is a nurse also a retired nurse um uh
there are many people who refuse to work
even in hospitals on the S there there
are some Adventists who who who do I've
pastored U any number of people who just
they waited until they could get an
opportunity to work um uh in a place
that doesn't out of allow them to work
on the Sabbath I had a a good friend his
wife Pastor is a nurse she came out of
the hospital setting and went into the
nursing home setting so that she
wouldn't have that those issues right so
a lot of these things are a product of
your your desire to serve the Lord
Faithfully right you know you you have a
skill you want to apply that skill yet
you also want to serve the Lord so you
must determine as God gives you the
unction amen how you're going to be
faithful to him given skill set that you
have amen but you have to do so prayer
prayerfully and with good good faith you
know the other side of the coin is also
true I have known people who make it a
point to try and work on Sabbath yeah
because they get an excuse you know that
I'm caring for the sick but then they
keep the money and so you know in the
sight of God uh when you know that you
should not keep the money that uh that
you make on Sabbath yeah uh and you use
it as an excuse to be able to work on
sabath
that's a different story it is it is you
know you can't you know you can't you
can't you can't play games with God God
knows your heart he knows where why
you're doing what you are doing and is
going to bless you accordingly so be
honest with the Lord be honest with your
employer be honest with the Lord be
honest with yourself and give the Lord
your very best you know in medical
missionary page uh I think it's 42 or so
Ellen White says your love for God your
desire for God your work for God should
not be one influence among many it ought
to be your Chief concern it ought to be
number one and everything every decision
you make ought to flow out of that
understanding so put God first and the
Lord will direct your steps another
thing which is important is you know
it's not God's plan that uh medical
personnel Works Sabbath after Sabbath
after Sabbath after Sabbath because they
really need to to be in church
absolutely they really need the
fellowship MH and so you know when you
make a contract uh make sure that you're
not going to be away 52 sabbaths out of
the Year yes good point because because
you really need to gather with with the
brothers and sisters for your own
edification yeah absolutely absenting
yourself from church really hurts you
and hurts your relationship with the
Lord uh if you're not there at all and
we miss you for great P out good point
uh Pastor Bor Al righty I think we have
done Justice to that particular question
thank you Gail very much for it now Lisa
Lisa
Leisa from Ethiopia amen uh and we
praise the Lord for a call from uh a
contact from Ethiopia um I am a Seventh
Day Adventist believer I'm glad to have
a chance to ask you pastors now I am a
university student not living with my
family and I departed from them for
education so here in University they
don't know about Sabbath they prepared
the food for us on Saturday and I am
eating the food that they prepared on
Sabbath day because it is difficult for
me to get it from another now what do
you think about this if I continue to
eat the food that is prepared on Sabbath
is there any problem with
that that's interesting question I think
we need to be um we have to go to the
Bible yeah to find the answer to that um
in Exodus 20 the fourth Commandment uh
says remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy six days you shall labor and do all
your work but the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord your God in it you
shall do no work you nor your son nor
your daughter nor your male servant nor
your female servant nor your cattle nor
your stranger who is within your Gates
that's a very important phrase within
your Gates right uh so uh you know if
you were home it would be different than
being in school where where other people
who are not Sabbath keepers are
preparing the meals yes correct and
therefore you have no control you have
no jurisdiction over what they do and um
it's just like you know they I think
that in this case she has to um not feel
that she's breaking the Sabbath by
taking partaking of the meal that is
given to her on that day so I mean I
think this important we have seen this
happening in convention
in in assemblies that are done we have
people that work that are not under our
care are not in control and they provide
meals and so I I don't see this would be
a Breaking of the Sabbath because she's
not the one that's paying or is being
responsible or or has a control over
these people you know so yeah I put the
three words under your control and I was
waiting to see how long before that that
phrase is going to come up and it came
up on the first answer they're not she's
not in control of them they're not
cooking at her Direction whether she
eats the food or not they're going to
cook so she is not directing them to sin
they're just doing their job uh and of
course U they don't have a Sabbath
Consciousness uh at this point in time
so I don't see that she is particularly
sinning by by eating the food Pastor
what do you think once again the
expression within your Gates you know
the the Sabbath commandment is addressed
to Israel yes of course it's also
addressed to the whole world world but
most of the world is totally ignorant to
the fact that the Sabbath you're not
supposed to be uh you know doing those
things uh but uh it's our role to let
people know about the Sabbath yes but
people who don't know who are cooking
and who are charging on Sabbath you know
the fourth Commandment at that
particular moment does not mean that the
person who is eating there is violating
the Commandment because they cooked on
Sabbath right yes I mean just think of
the examples of the you know the Hebrew
Boys in in Babylon um they had no
control on what meals was done and and
you know we don't hear anywhere where he
stopped eating on the seventh day
Sabbath I mean he he asked for 10 days
remember the 10 days period of trial he
didn't say okay I'm going to skip a meal
on the seventh day you know he had he
understood there was no control over
these elements what he could control was
what he could eat so if they're serving
you needs and things that are contrary
to God's word well you got to reject
that you know that's what you can do but
um going to try to say that you have to
uh abstain from eating on the seventh
day
because hidden people or those that
don't understand the concept of B
Sabbath are preparing is probably uh
taking this the Commandment in in a in a
wrong way approach it would have been
very interesting yeah to see how they
kept the Sabbath in Babylon yeah yeah
you know I had not thought about that
well now think but you know uh how could
these young men yeah live according to
their principles on the Sabbath uh in
Babylon I agree with you what you said
about the food that they ate yeah but
you know what about other
responsibilities that the government
expected we don't have light on that
yeah but a they lived in harmony
with God's principles because they did
it in the diet issue they did it when
the image was raised Daniel did it later
on in life when he was thrown into the
lion's den so we know they we're
faithful yeah absolutely and so that's
the bottom line let's be faithful
ourselves amen and if other people
because of ignorance uh you know are not
keeping the Sabbath we have no control
over that right and and you know we we
we think about large Gatherings like ASI
every year a general conference every
five years the thing you can control is
is the Commerce end of it paying for
your meals before Sabbath so that you're
not handling money and and doing that
kind of thing but the food itself is
exist whether you eat it or not so you
do what you can this is not a pay to eat
kind of situation they're going to be
Ser eating and serving so I I I think we
we we we we've answered well uh and
helping her out and maybe you know when
it comes to pain maybe she make an
arrangement to to pay for her meal on on
Friday you know Friday MH uh so we don't
know all the circumstances but it would
be better to pay for the meals on Friday
right in most schools uh you can do like
a whole trimester or whatever
according defense so that's why most
likely she's not really paying and if
she was paying then you would say yeah
that's that's a mistake you know buy
something uh
beforehand all right all right thank you
Lisa uh well done um this is anonymous
the person wants to be anonymous
um and no
location okay my husband has decided to
divorce me and I'm going to read most of
this and try to leave leave out just a
little bit he's dissatisfied with the
marriage because they do not emulate the
porn stars that he watches regularly um
he says I'm not submitting or being a
Godly wife by doing the things that he
wants however the things he requests
impact my spirituality my spiritual
relationship and I believe uh with God
and I believe they are
perversions as his perversions have led
him to set up a profile on a dating
website we are still married I'm unable
am I unable to marry again I was willing
to remain in the marriage to try to work
uh through these problems it seems that
he is has committed adultery mentally
and emotionally as well as left their
marriage without just cause so this is a
a a complicated situation but not an
unusual one uh I have pastored two
people two couples with pretty much the
same issues um uh by the time I came to
into it the the man had already
committed adultery so it was a little
cleaner than this but if he has not
committed adultery he's well on his way
U and mentally he's he has left the
marriage so what do we say to this
person who for good reasons I suspect is
remaining remaining
anonymous
well you know we I I would like to just
kind of go to the Book of Matthew
Chapter 5 MH and Christ sort of you know
confirms what she has felt and what you
were mentioning Pastor you know that you
know what happened to him already to her
husband it says uh verse uh 27 and 28 of
Matthew 5 you have heard that it was
said of by them of all time thou shall
not commit adultery but I said unto you
that whosoever lookth on a woman to last
after her her cath commit adultery with
her already in his heart so and then he
says you know if die right I offend thee
pluck it out and cast it from thee so
it's interesting that here we see
someone that has
been already into pornography who has
already Venter into mental emotional
adultery and it's going against the
principles of keeping the matrimony the
Santi of marriage as between just you
know a couple just man and wife and so
um if he has already established this
principle and he's already has gone with
dating profiles and these kind of things
he is in adultery I mean he has not
committed necessarily the act itself but
according to the Bible he already has
divorced his wife if you will he has
committed adultery in his wife you know
with his wife so um according to the
Bible and what Christ said she would be
free to be married again because her
husband has committed adultery yeah you
know the Apostle Paul uh in more than
one place in his writings U has
something to say about this he uses the
expression in the
lord and basically that means that by
extension it would mean that if the
husband requests something of the wife
that is contrary to to her conscience
which is wron MHM she has a right to um
to not follow what the husband demands
absolutely uh you know there there are
certain uh sexual aberrations that could
be committed in marriage which were are
off limits absolutely and so and so the
wife does has to commit to what her
husband uh uh asks her to do as long as
it is in the Lord amen in other words as
long as it doesn't go against biblical
principles or her own conscience right
and so you know I I feel sorry for this
for this person who's writing here uh
because one of the biggest problems that
exists in the world today and not only
in the world but in the church is the
issue of pornography you know uh if you
have a wife you should be satisfied with
with your wife amen and you should and
you should respect her convictions of
conscience absolutely and it's is a is a
call I believe you know for for for
young women and men to remember that is
not just the act of adultery but this
perversions or this you know deviating
from that purity of of Santi of marriage
it's really the way the enemy is
destroying true un you know Oneness
unity in marriages and is really
destroying a relationship of trust of
love and instead is being filled with
lust and animal passions so I think that
it's it's a you know it's a sad
situation I feel terribly for her but I
believe that she has ad just she has
just caused to to divorce that man yeah
I I I well I think he's leading out on a
divorce I think he's trying to step out
from her right yeah but um truth be told
you can't live God hasn't called anybody
to to match anybody's Fantasy Life you
know you can't you can't do that the
things that he sees on know sites you
can't you can't keep up with that and I
don't think God asks you to do that um I
think Pastor B's statement is very very
true obey in the Lord and a lot of
things that pop into people's brains
because of what they say are not of the
lord they're not in the Lord and if you
feel that is impacting on your
relationship with God then you've got to
to to draw the line if he's not
satisfied then he's going to go you're
not kicking him out uh so I think your
conscience is clear and if he he does
pull the trigger on the marriage and
ends it then I believe that you are you
are are just and right to to find a good
Christian man yeah there there are two
two points uh in summary uh that I want
to emphasize concerning this number one
is she does have biblical grounds to get
remarried and number two I pity the
woman that he marries
next sad yes well said well said well um
we've come down to the end of a very
interesting program and again we
encourage you to to write us our time
has fast slipped into eternity now we
ask you to bless uh the Lord and keep us
in your prayers as we see you again soon
bye-bye and may God bless
[Music]
you